a call to line up for military exercises
is something these soldiers are used to
but for the past two months these South
Sudanese troops have been training
alongside other armed groups some of
whom they once fought on the battlefield
during South Sudan's Civil War that all
here regarded them die now you can fight
there's no different now there's no Iowa
there's no SS video foundational so some
of these fighters gathered here are
parts of the government forces others
come from the main armed opposition
called the Sudan People's Liberation
Movement in opposition and a few from
the armed group known as South Sudan's
opposition alliance this is one of the
16 such camps around the country where
the fighters are trained to form a
unified national army it was set up
after a 20-18 peace deal to end the five
year long conflict that's killed nearly
400,000 people and displaced
a third of the country's 12 million
population the deal states that 41,500
out of the 83,000 forces from the
warring sides are to be trained before
the formation of a transitional
government that government was partially
formed last weekend when five vice
presidents were sworn in this training
camp in the West of South Sudan holds
about 1,500 soldiers from the three
different sides but they're not in equal
numbers even though they're supposed to
be the opposition says transporting
soldiers from their areas through the
camps is difficult and that's just one
of the many issues affecting the
training and reunification of the forces
soldiers say the camp lacks many basic
needs making life inside hard there is
no medicine and we sleep in the open
where it's cold and the needs for female
soldiers and not met Moya comma there is
no water sometimes and there is no place
to sleep and we train in our slippers
and sometimes barefoot which is hard and
we don't have uniforms the joint
monitoring and evaluation Commission
j-mac the body tasked with monitoring
the implementation of the deal has
reported that since the training sites
were established hundreds of soldiers
have abandoned them due to poor
conditions shortage of funds is another
big challenge the government made a
pledge of a hundred million dollars
which we felt would be sufficient to do
this initial training
unfortunately not all of those resources
have come from the government we've
received about 16 million of which of
the other hundred million dollars so we
continue to encourage the government to
make available those remaining funds so
that we can really see an improvement in
those conditions within those trading
centers a well trained and disciplined
army is crucial for South Sudan's
transitional period and to avoid a
return to were soldiers here say they
want to be part of a united army but how
soon that happens depends on those
leading them and the country
Hiba Morgan al-jazeera Murray team South
Sudan